vingt-deux joueurs deux équipes un
ballon le match peut commencer
pour cette rencontre l'italie affronte
l'espagne ils jouent avec leurs doigts
bienvenue à la coupe du monde de
supputer au football de table le joueur
attaquant est celui qui touche le ballon
donc tant qu'il touche le ballon et
qu'il ne l'envoie pas ni à l'extérieur
du terrain ni sur un adversaire
il en conserve la possession à chaque
fois que l'attaquant touche le ballon
une fois le défenseur a la possibilité
de jouer ce qu'on appelle un coup de
défense pour freiner la progression de
l'attaquant mais ce coup de défense ne
doit rien toucher d'autres ni le ballon
ni en attaquant né une figurine
défenseur précision concentration jeu
défensif ou jeu d'attaquant 24 nations
se sont affrontées dans cette 24e
édition qui se jouait pour la première
fois à elancourt c'est la première fois
qu'on joue en france après plusieurs
années et l'encours est une belle ville
l'an passé c'était une belle compétition
aussi mais cette année les organisateurs
ont fait encore mieux ce soit en france
et c'est bien et ça développe aussi le
football de table français qui est pas
très connu par rapport à d'autres pays
comme l'italie ou la belgique
dix mille pratiquants sont aujourd'hui
classés mondialement le pays le mieux
représenté c'est l'italie avait plus de
1000 joueurs